[Musique]
aux anneaux mustier vous avez entrepris
d'être non seulement philosophe mais
également avocat pénaliste aurait dû lui
mettre les deux fois dans le cul à ce
bâtard c'est l'heure de l'apéro sri
lanka historique qu avec moi je lui est
entre bonnes mains
on sentit frères salut papa m'a dit
qu'il travaillait sur simone de beauvoir
ouais mais je suis prêt c'est terminé
[Musique]
hasta la victoria siempre papa bien
s'amuser mon petit frère jules juin il
est utile mais son jus d'orange veut
avec ou sans contenu
[Musique]
c'est un test qui vise à confirmer un
diagnostic de ltc des listings je
traduis crise de puberté à retardement
vincee triangle à la passe en profondeur
rien n'était dit oui mais je veux plutôt
prendre la rôtisserie le kawbab
mademoiselle et take you may 1 qu'un
front + 1 avec un rendu qu'un free h 15
pour la vache a remis des dons arrêté
[Applaudissements]
problème
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
je vais désavantage je suis prêt
soir
[Musique]
guérin
du jour j
voilà ton but
à
dans madame angot gens